wird es am morgen noch ein ja so
genanntes kleines gipfeltreffen geben da
wird auch der französische präsident
kommen es wird der englische
premierminister kommen es wird der
italienische ministerpräsident kommen da
sitzen dann politiker zusammen bei denen
jetzt schon klar ist dass sich in
nächster zeit einiges ändern wird der
amerikanische präsident hat jetzt noch
bis januar eine präsidentschaft sowohl
die bundeskanzlerin als auch der
französische präsident müssen im
kommenden jahr wahlen bestehen und von
david cameron weiß man nicht ob er nach
dem 23 juni noch premierminister sein
wird spielt so was auch eine rolle bei
solchen gesprächen ist vielleicht auch
deshalb im moment ein gewisser zeitdruck
da ich glaube die probleme drängen so
arg das ist eher der haupt druck der
momentan dazu führt dass man die
kombination der schwierigkeiten
wir setzen das gespräch natürlich gleich
fort denn im prinzip sind uns die
inhalte schon wichtiger als jedes
zeremoniell aber keine frage ein empfang
mit militärischen ehren eines
amerikanischen präsidenten in den
herrenhäuser gärten in hannover und dann
auch noch bei sonnenschein das ist etwas
was wir alle gemeinsam jetzt ja durchaus
auch sehen wollen und sehen werden
also zu den festen zeremoniell gehört
auch dass die musik nicht gleich beginnt
alle die wir vorher gesehen haben haben
jetzt die gelegenheit den amerikanischen
präsidenten noch einmal persönlich zu
begrüßen und natürlich auch die
bundeskanzlerin
ja
ok
war
die
also was man als reporter ja durchaus
mal loben darf zwischendurch sechs bis
neun grad war die wettervorhersage und
das musikkorps ist er zwei stunden hier
respekt also vor den musikern die bei
diesen temperaturen draußen spielen
wenn die sonne die verben eher die
herzen als den körper im moment
professor jäger wir erleben eine
bundeskanzlerin die da gelöst und
plaudernd mit dem amerikanischen
präsidenten über den vorplatz geht
gleich haben sie aber schwere themen vor
sich und müssen harte gespräche führen
das zeremoniell war also möglicherweise
für die beiden auch einen moment kraft
zu schöpfen
das war der auftakt wobei das erste
thema dass sie miteinander besprechen
vor allem eines ist für beide in die
gleiche richtung wollen nämlich ein
transatlantisches freihandelsabkommen
man handels und investitionsabkommen zu
erzielen
und sie haben dabei die gemeinsame
aufgabe aber da gibt es keinen großen
streit außer in details über die
generelle richtung geht die sie hier
gehen wollen
das wird schwieriger werden wenn eben
andere themen mit auf dem tisch liegen
die insbesondere die lage im
mittelmeerraum in lybien in syrien und
die flüchtlingsfrage betreffen auch
themen die hier besprochen werden die ja
miteinander zusammenhängen und wo sich
die usa eigentlich nur sehr peripher
über die nato engagieren wollen und
ansonsten sehr sehr zurückhaltend sind
und die europäer wie wir in den letzten
monaten ja schmerzlich erfahren mussten
nicht in der lage sind wirklich zu
entscheidungen zu kommen die sie
gemeinsam tragen und die sie auch in die
lage versetzen
in diesen konflikten wirklich so zu
handeln dass ergebnisse erzielt werden
die in kurzer oder gar mittlerer frist
nun wirklich etwas ändern
das sind dem da gibt es unterschiedliche
akzente das wird mit sicherheit auch
möglicherweise doch es wird gesprochen
werden über die den nato gipfel in
warschau der ansteht
das ist aus sicht der usa nochmal
wichtiger punkt und das wird der nächste
reise von roma nach
das war also der empfang mit
militärischen ehren in den herrenhäuser
gärten films gesehen bundeskanzlerin und
der amerikanische präsident haben sich
jetzt zurückgezogen in dem gebäude um
ihre gespräche aufzunehmen
sie werden die nächste stunde dort
gespräche führen und es wird am späteren
nachmittag dann die genaue zeit wenn man
noch bekannt gegeben und werde es
natürlich auch live übertragen
eine pressekonferenz der beiden geben um
16.40 höre ich ist der aktuelle stand
wenn es bei diesem zeitplan bleibt dann
wird phoenix um 1640 diese
pressekonferenz übertragen dies ist
übrigens der gegen blick jetzt sozusagen
gewesen aus der perspektive der beiden
von dem balkon auf dem sie eben standen
über den park und am ende des parks
stehen diese kleinen bühnen der
fernsehanstalten
auch wir sehen jetzt das bild das sie
sehen auch wir sehen jetzt nicht mehr in
das gebäude hinein auch wir müssen jetzt
sozusagen warten bis die gespräche
beendet sind und in der pressekonferenz
dann tatsächlich bekannt wird zu welchen
ergebnissen mann kam alles was wir bis
jetzt besprechen konnten waren
mutmaßungen aufgrund der im moment
gegebenen voraussetzungen und waren die
inhalte die wir erwarten vom heutigen
tag
fakt ist das ist kein höflichkeitsbesuch
das ist kein ausflug das ist keine
vergnügungsreise fakt ist das ist der
besuch des amerikanischen präsidenten
bei der hannover messe die heute abend
eröffnen wird mit der bundeskanzlerin
und dies war sozusagen die postkarte
dies war der farbiger und schöner
auftakt dieser ganzen veranstaltung aber
die wichtigen dinge die werden jetzt
zunächst mal hinter den kulissen
besprochen und anschließend wird es dazu
die pressekonferenz geben
das musikkorps zieht jetzt noch einmal
durch die herrenhäuser gärten das sind
natürlich bilder die um die welt gehen
und die die stadt hannover sehr sehr
gerne sehen wird gott sei dank jetzt
kein graupelschauer
es regelt auch nicht die sonne scheint
über hannover und der amerikanische
präsident und die bundeskanzlerin
sprechen über wichtigen themen dieser
welt
professor jäger der fahrplan für heute
und für morgen der sehr eng gesteckt
nach der pressekonferenz am späten
nachmittag hier in den herrenhäuser
gärten wird präsident obama mit der
kanzlerin zum kongresszentrum fahren
wird dort die hannover messe eröffnen
anschließend wird es noch ein abendessen
wiederum hier geben mit der kanzlerin
morgen früh den messe rundgang
anschließend wird eine rede halten auf
dem messegelände und ab mittag gibt es
dann diesen kleinen gipfel
ich hab es denn das ganz plötzlich dass
es erst vor drei tagen bekannt geworden
mal eben so ein gipfel veranstaltet wird
der eine mini ausgabe eines g7 oder g8
gipfels ist sind die wichtigen
europäischen staaten hier zusammen
gekommen und es zu nennen dass es einen
teil der g7 ist ist der versuch zu sagen
dass sie nicht die europäischen staaten
die großen die sich mit den usa treffen
denn das ist eigentlich was wirklich
geschieht dass es hier eine teil der
europäischen union der privilegiert mit
dem amerikanischen präsidenten spricht
der diese europa rasierer nicht zuletzt
deshalb unternommen hat um in
großbritannien vehement dafür zu werben
dass großbritannien in der europäischen
union bleibt wenn man vor einiger zeit
gesagt der europa ist nicht der herzens
kontinent obamas er spielt in seinem
außenpolitischen denkt nicht die die
zentrale rolle
aber europa würde sofort eine viel
höhere rolle spielen wenn es zu
turbulenzen kommt wenn von einem
möglichen austritt großbritanniens aus
der europäischen union nicht nur
wirtschaftliche sondern auch politische
turbulenzen zu erwarten wären und das
ist etwas das liegt im interesse der usa
dass die europäische union zusammen
bleibt das ist das zentrale interesse in
dem sich obama mit bundeskanzlerin
merkel nun völlig identisch trifft sie
sollen zusammen bleiben und dazu sind
eine reihe von problemen zu lösen die
flüchtlingsfrage gehört dazu das gehört
da die sicherheit im osten und im süden
dazu die sicherung der grenzen
das sind alles themen die dann mit auf
den tisch kommen wenn die anderen
am montag dann hier mit merkel und obama
zusammensetzen
aber dann hätte ja der besuch des
amerikanischen präsidenten in hannover
hier ganz plötzlich wenn es so kommt wie
sie sagen eine bedeutung die weit weit
über alles hinausgeht was mit den
letzten tagen und wochen ja erwarten
durfte sie geht über der besuch geht
über tipp weit hinaus dass sich auch nun
es wird tipp auch mit sicherheit eine
rolle spielen wenn im kernort und und
rennt sie mit bei sind aber da wird es
eben auch um die krisenherde um die eu
von der ukraine über syrien bis nach
libyen gehen und es werden diese fragen
mit auf den tisch kommen
und insofern hat er eine weit über die
messe eröffnung hinaus gehende
bedeutungen ich trinke man muss sich das
so vorstellen der neunzigsten geburtstag
der queen
das war der anlass dass obama in london
war aber im ging es eigentlich um
wahlkampf für cameron wollte er
unterstützen hier wollte er die
deutliche botschaft sagen großbritannien
wenn ihr nicht mehr in der europäischen
union seit glaubt nicht dass er
besondere beziehung zu den usa ab die
das ausgleichen können
und hier ist dass die eröffnung der
hannover messe die der anlass ist um mit
den staats und regierungschefs diese
wichtigen fragen zu besprechen